Speaker 1: One of the things that is a troubling
sign for Joe Biden is that even some Democrats,
now elected Democrats, are backing away from
saying, absolutely, I would support Joe Biden's
reelection in 2024. We're going to look at a
clip of Tim Ryan, who I support in his race
in Ohio for the Senate. It's a very important
race actually. He's running against JP, right?
JD Mandel No, he's running against JD Vance and
Tim Ryan's been on the show. I think he's I think
he's great. I hope that he wins in Ohio, but he is
correctly reading the mood on the ground in Ohio,
which is that even Democrats don't really
want Joe Biden to run for reelection.
Now, where do I get that?
Well, I get it from polling.
There is a majority of Democrats at this point
that want someone other than Joe Biden to be the
nominee. In 2024, a Tim Ryan appeared on Fox News
and he was asked, would you support Joe Biden's
reelection in 2024? And he basically punts. And
I think that there is a lot to read into the
punting, but let's take a look at the clip first.
Speaker 2: So we'll keep watching all of that.
Final question to you. There was the first
presidential primary state New Hampshire
poll that came out yesterday, and it showed
support for this president, President Joe Biden,
for his reelection. It is plummeting. In fact,
it suggested that Biden and booted edge are
now tied in a hypothetical 2024 presidential
primary matchup. Do you support the president
in his reelection bid?
Speaker 3: I'm working now.
Speaker 1: By the way, the question's a little bit
silly because Joe Biden hasn't actually filed for
reelection. So so the question is a little bit
wonky. Now what? The question is a little bit
squishy, but let's listen to the answer.
Speaker 3: On my own election.
And that's all I'm focused on.
Speaker 1: And sorry I talked over the key
moment. So let's back it up and take it from the.
Speaker 2: President in his reelection bid.
Speaker 3: I'm working on my own election and
that's all I'm focused on right now. We've got
a little under four months here in Ohio and we're
running a great campaign. We're up in the polls
and working really hard. So I'm just going to
focus on that and then we can chat about that.
After I win and get in the United States
Senate, I'll be happy to comment. Well.
Speaker 2: It was it was noted that the president
held an event there in your state recently,
a speech on the economy. I believe if my
memory serves me and you didn't show, that
was certainly a message you were sending, right?
Speaker 3: Well, it was an event where we saved
100,000 pensions in Ohio through the rescue
package, which was significant. Many of those
Teamsters working class people, it was a great
thing. But I had commitments in southern Ohio
and I'm not going to back out on normal Ohioans,
average Ohioans to like a schedule that I had and
then leave them to go see the president. Like, I'm
not doing that stuff. These are great people and
I'm going to I'm going to keep my meetings,
but we got to get focused on the economy.
Speaker 1: All right. So so, I mean,
listen, he's doing some dancing,
and rightly so. I had a commitment and the economy
is the focus and all these things. This is not a
hard thing to dance around if you want to send
a different message. Right. Tim Ryan could say,
you know, it's too early to talk about 20, 24, but
I know that Democrats will select a great nominee
and I will support that nominee. Right. Okay. So
you could he could have said something like that.
He didn't say that. And there are two
interpretations. One, Tim Ryan doesn't really
like Joe Biden for president. I actually don't
think that's the case. I think Tim Ryan likes Joe
Biden. Absolutely fine. Tim Ryan is trying to win
a Senate seat in a sometimes red state of Ohio,
which would be hugely impactful for Democrats in
the Senate when there is a huge fight for who's
going to control the Senate next time. Tim
Ryan accurately believes that Ohio Democrats
and independents and maybe some Republicans
who could vote for him in November
might be soured on Biden. Why do I say Tim Ryan
accurately believes that? Because that's what
the polling shows. And I know people get mad at
me, but Joe Biden has a low approval rating. It's
historically low. It's the lowest at this point
in his presidency compared to any president going
all the way back to Truman in the second year
of his presidency, in the middle of the 1940s.
So it is correct as an assessment that Biden's
not popular. And my guess would be that Tim Ryan,
being an Ohio congressman and wanting to be an
Ohio senator, is aware that in Ohio in particular,
the numbers might be even worse for Biden than
they are nationally. But the point here is.
This can become a self-fulfilling feedback loop.
The public becomes disillusioned with Biden, which
is happening. It's what the approval rating shows.
And then this causes Democratic elected officials
to back away from Biden, which furthers the
implausibility of a successful reelection
campaign, which further reduces the number of
people that want Biden to run again. It can
become this feedback loop, and it sort of seems to
be happening. If the best strategy remember in too
long and we think now in 2008 when it was McCain
versus Obama, Obama, George W Bush was basically
missing from the campaign trail. George W
Bush was a drag down based on his approval
for Republicans wanting to get elected, John
McCain included. Is it possible that Biden is
going to end up being the same? And the question
will be answered in the next few months. Does Joe
Biden start showing up at rallies in support of
2022 Democratic candidates? Let me know what you
think. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman. Make
sure you're following me there. I would love it
if you signed up for The David Pakman Show
membership program, which you can do at join
Packman dot com. We do depend on the support of
our audience, people listening to the podcast,
listening on the radio, watching on TV, watching
clips on YouTube, and the primary source of that
support is the membership program, all of these
other platforms where one can support independent
creators. They take these slices of every payment.
Some take 5%, some take 20, 20, 30, 40, even
percent. When you sign up at joint pack mint.com,
2% of your payment goes to processing the credit
and debit cards and we keep the rest. Meaning
the money really comes to the show and stays
within the show. It also comes with great perks,
strong perks, including the Daily Bonus Show,
as well as commercial free audio and video streams
of the show. Sign up at join pacman dot com.